So we just finished lesson zero, which
was an introduction. In this lesson, lesson one,
we will build two main projects while
using functions. Now, towards the end of this
lesson we will present a scenario where
functions won't quite present a very eloquent solution.
That will pave the way for us to learn new stuff in lesson two and three.
>> Now if you feel extremely
comfortable with functions and understand their limitations
completely you should consider moving on to the next lesson, however
if you feel like you want to learn more about functions
in the Python programming language, continue to take this lesson, watch
the next video, we will use it to write our first program.